before we say goodbye we like to play a  quick round of truth or dare  you get to ask me anything or dare me to  do anything and i go there so chloe here  you are how are you today i'm great how  are you you look lovely thank you you're  welcome truth or dare  dare do it what what do i do so i've had  a really old voicemail from my whole  life and i dare you to record my  voicemail for me  i would be honored too  okay  give me your phone  okay um  okay  hi this is drew barrymore i'm recording  the outgoing message for chloe's inbox  please leave a message but also remember  to have a wonderful day thank you so  much  felt a lot of pressure i really wanted  to get it right  oh gosh  thank you chloe  thank you for letting me be a part of  your voice now